only on cbs morning's billionaire
philanthropist melinda french-gates is
talking in detail about her high-profile
divorce from microsoft co-founder that's
bill gates bill and melinda gates as you
may have heard were married for 27 years
before they announced their split last
may it made national news and was a
shock to many people we sat down with
melinda for her first tv interview about
the announcement this is a preview
after the news came out it was revealed
that bill gates admitted that he had had
an affair in the marriage and
at that time did you think we're going
to work through this how did you handle
something like that
well i certainly believe in forgiveness
so i thought we had worked through some
of that it wasn't one moment or one
specific thing that happened there just
came a point in time where there was
enough there that i realized it just
wasn't healthy and i couldn't trust what
we had did you have moments where you
were just so angry did you have moments
that you were just in such pain i'm
because people look at you melinda
french gates and say she has it all well
i think it's really important to say
look i had a lot of tears for many days
i mean days where i'm literally laying
on the floor in the carpet you know this
close to me thinking
how can this be how can i get up how am
i going to move forward in days i
certainly was angry that's part of the
grieving process you're grieving
a loss of something you thought you had
and thought you had for your lifetime
i mean this is painful stuff
and at the end of the day though i
started on this journey of healing and i
feel like i'm starting to get to the
other side and i do feel like i'm i'm
turning a page in the chapter now i mean
it's 2022 and i'm actually really
excited about what's to come in life
ahead for me
i think a lot of women will relate to
her conversation we'll have more of our
exclusive it's a wide-ranging interview
with melinda french gates tomorrow on
cbs mornings guys we should say we did
not just focus on the divorce this is a
very strong accomplished woman and she
had lots to say but listen divorce is
painful under the best of circumstances
really painful when it's on the evening
news and everybody's talking about it
and nobody really knows nobody really
knows what happens behind closed doors
but this is not a oh woe is me
or i'm so sad or i'm sitting in the
fetal position she is strong she is
ready to move on with her life and she's
decided that she wanted to talk about it
because there was so much in the news so
much chatter some of it incorrect and
she just wanted people to know this is
who i am and this is what i'm doing and
doing is the word she's doing a lot
that's right because of the microsoft
brand the wealth the philanthropy and of
course the high profile divorce i mean
they've been living under the microscope
of the public so we're looking forward
to this conversation gail thank you so
much